all right so welcome everybody um my
name is peter bartlett i'm the associate
director here at uh the simons institute
uh we run these collaborative programs
two a semester and uh
this uh learning and games program is
one of those two this semester
um that's brought something like 75
people or bringing something like 75
people to berkeley
welcome to the
first workshop for the learning and
games program adversarial approaches in
machine learning
uh
let me start by saying a big thank you
to the to the organizers costas
duskalakis now
mike jordan uh asu as douglas
uh giorgios pilluras and vasila
siricanus thanks to all those folks
it'll be a very exciting program
this week
i'll let costas introduce the workshop
in a moment i just wanted to say a few
words about logistics for those of you
who haven't been here for previous
workshops
we do ask you to keep your masks on
indoors
at least for this week
the food and drinks please please enjoy
them outside uh for lunch lunch breaks
you're on your own there are lockers on
the far side of the building if you want
to leave stuff in those there's a pin
code on the lockers
um
uh we have omid pharr our videographer
who'll be helping speakers hook up their
computers and and
get microphones set up and so on
uh and also
uh to introduce kailani penland who's
done all the local organization a big
thank you to kelania
all right
[Music]
all right thank you very much uh thank
you very much peter
uh
so yeah on behalf of the organizers of
this workshop i'd like to welcome
everybody who is physically present and
who's watching us online
indeed this is the first workshop of the
learning and games program
and this workshop is devoted to
adversarial approaches in
machine learning
so
so min max optimization has a long
history
uh it's intimately related to the
foundations of game theory
optimization mathematical programming
online learning theory
and has found a ton of applications in
various theoretical and applied fields
but it keeps on giving so we still don't
understand
you know the full scope of its
applications and
specifically
in recent years we don't understand
the applications that arise from its
application
uh the questions that arise from its
applications to machine learning
and uh the purpose of this uh
workshop is to understand uh
those applications and dive deeper into
both the um optimization aspects uh of
those applications but also
uh thinking about uh
uh you know the future potential of
future applications and uh you know
scoping
uh you know the full range of both the
theory and the practice uh of uh
min max optimization in this field
uh
so we have an excellent uh sequence of
talks uh planned for you
i hope you enjoy it
and without further ado let me
introduce yank chai who's a professor at
yale university
uh who's our first speaker and uh yeah
yeah take it away
[Music]
thank you guys um so it's great pleasure
to be here uh
and today i want to talk about our new
result on the last literary convergence
uh for constraining max optimization
problem
and in particular uh i would like to
share a new approach we developed to get
the result that is based on sum of
squares program
all right uh yeah so the work is with
the
my student are yuris uh economo with
cheongjung uh those are in the audience
uh
all right uh
start
and
so my my open sentence is basically what
classes just set so i will be looking at
me max optimization
and also its generalization known as the
variation in qualities in this talk
so you know uh as we all know this uh me
max optimization plays a very central
role in game theory optimization online
learning but has recently found a lot of
applications in machine learning
for example the training of gans
adversary examples and reinforcement
learning
so what i would like to look at is a
particular important class here the
convex concave case
that is super amenable to theoretical
analysis
so just let me remind you the setting
so you have two compact comics that's x
and y
and you have a loss function l that is
continuous and convex concave
so commas concave here means that l is
convex in x if you fix y
and it's concave in y if you fix x
and the goal is to find the mean max
solution
of this l
and so if you look at this
a very natural interpretation of this is
you can think of this as a two-player
zero-sum game
between the meme player who controls x
and a max player who controls y
while the mean player pays the max
player of x y
okay and
the the fundamental result by von
neumann showed that
in fact the order you take mean and max
doesn't matter me max is the same as max
mean
and this has a very important
implication for game theory
uh that is uh the equilibrium of this
zero sum game
is actually the same as the mini max
points
in this uh problem okay
so uh
so that's you know the structure of
the equilibrium in this game
and how how can we you know find uh such
equilibrium
and uh conventional wisdom tells us that
you can just run no regret online
learning algorithms so in particular for
example online gradient descent
if you run those the strategies will
converge to equilibrium
so i'm putting converge in quotes and
i'll explain why i put them in codes uh
in the next line
all right
okay so uh here i have a very simple
example
so the loss function is just x times y
and x y are scalars okay really simple
case
and let's say i'm running gradient
descent ascent
so here x is the mean player
so i'm subtracting the gradient of the
loss function y is the max player so i'm
adding the loss function the grading of
the loss function
and
so in this case uh if the equilibrium is
the equilibrium is at the middle which
is the zero zero
and suppose you start the algorithm
somewhere here
what happens is actually the trajectory
will spiral out
instead of converging to the equilibrium
you actually would spiral out
okay
and this is not a phenomenon just
happens in this or like maybe contrived
simple theoretical example people
observe this in practice as well
and so
what's going on all right so then i just
say that no
the equilibrium will come
the algorithm will converge to
equilibrium
so turns out
the reason is that
the convergence result from these costal
papers actually looks at a weaker notion
of convergence
which is known as the average x-ray
convergence
what that means is that if you run the
algorithms for capital t steps
you take the time average of those
iterates
that time average converges to the
equilibrium okay and that is consistent
with the picture here right so if you
take the time merge of this trajectory
it will get close to the center
but this is kind of really weak notion
of convergence
well
basically if you use that notion that we
can say the moon is converging to the
earth right
and so in this talk i would like to look
at a stronger notion of convergence
uh that is known as the last litter
convergence
all right so what i'm asking here is if
we run the algorithm for capital t steps
i want the last iterator to get close to
the equilibrium as as i increase capital
t
all right
so of course this is a theoretically
more appealing notion of convergence
uh but i would like to argue there are
several
well i'll give you two other reasons why
we should care about
lacity convergence
um so the first reason is that uh
you know so i'm looking at commerce
concave settings but maybe eventually we
would like to go to non-convex and
uncomplete settings
um
so if you're in a non-convex setting
taking the time average might not make
sense right so a big rationale for
taking time averages because you have
complexity
so without convexity you know taking
time merge does not really make sense so
maybe they really want to understand
what's happening with the last iterate
and it's important to develop tools to
understand the last structure okay so
let's start with basic convex concave
setting to develop those tools
uh the second thing is that
so uh if you just have a central entity
you want to compute the equilibrium
you can use this average iterate
convergence algorithms that's totally
fine
but maybe
you would like to think about these
algorithms
as dynamics that are run by agents so
each agent has an independent copy of
this algorithm and they're running
independently
so in that case average iterate
convergence does not really tell you
what happens in the system
only at the last literary convergence
mode okay so that's the second reason
why i want to you know look at lassiter
convergence
all right
so that's
uh the convergence measure i want to
think about
all right so let's look at the this
issue a bit more uh to understand
why we have this spiraling out behavior
if you run gradient descent ascent
so uh
so when we start the algorithm here
the grading is going to push it to the
blue point and so on so forth okay
so when we see the spiraling out
behavior
what happens is usually
or exactly this is the case here
that the the algorithm gives you the raw
momentum it actually pushes away from
the center okay
and so if you want to get lost citrate
convergence your algorithm will need to
correct this momentum okay
and
you know a natural idea is
perhaps
we can come up with an algorithm that's
supposed to say it starts with you know
here at the end
and it spirals in
okay if we can come up with the
algorithm that has this kind of behavior
corrects the momentum it will converge
and turns out there is an algorithm that
does that
which is known as the proximal point
method
it's very similar to gda
the only difference is that
i'm not updating using the gradient at
the t step
i'm updating using the gradient at the
next step at a t plus one step okay this
might seem like a minor change but it's
actually a big deal because
uh now this one iteration
is a fixed point computation problem
okay
because i don't know what's t plus one
it's a fixed point okay so quite
expensive to do
but if you can do it
you will sparrow it okay
and by the way i'm presenting these in
unconstrained settings just to make the
point uh but later on i will go to
constraint setting you need to make
projections as well
all
right
okay so proximal point corrects the
momentum
but it's an implicit method it's
expensive to implement
uh the good news is uh there are
actually several
easy to implement exclusive methods that
can be viewed as approximations to the
proximal method
so i'm just introducing two very well
known ones
the first one is the extra gradient
method by kappalevich
the second one is the optimistic
gradient descent ascend by pop off
and i just want to point out like these
two algorithms have been shown to be
able to improve the training dynamics of
gans in practice
so um so for this talk i would really
want to look at extra gradient method
right
so uh
what are the existing results for
elasticity convergence
i'm borrowing this slide from kostas
tutorial so
so if you want uh asymptotic convergence
in the lastiture sense
actually the classical results already
give us the answer
uh so asymptotic convergence means that
if you take capital t to the limit it
will converge to the equilibrium all
right
of course uh we would like uh to know
the convergence rate
what do we know about the last liter
convergence rate
so in the unconstrained setting uh
there has been a lot of interest in
understanding this setting
and i think it's fair to say that by now
we have a quite clear understanding of
this case right
but what if you have constraints
so in that case the results are much
sparser
and i would say it's mostly unclear
and let me just uh
repeat the open question that causes
raise in his uh tutorial
that is
can we get polynomial in one over t and
dimension last letter convergence rates
in the constraint case
okay
so the result i want to show you today
is an answer to this open question
so we show that
if you run the extra gradient algorithm
with constant step size
you will get the last conversion
straight that looks like the following
you have polynomial dependence on the
dimension and divided by root t
okay
and this works for arbitrary comics
constraint sets
all right
and in fact this actually is the tight
last convergence rate in a quite strong
sense
i will show you more formally what i
mean by that all right
okay uh questions about the result
okay
let me move on
okay so before i can describe the result
formally
let me
fix the notation
okay so i'm looking at a smooth complex
concave mmx optimization problem
so to
make the notation lighter
i'm going to use this uh way to write
things
so i'm going to write z
as the cartesian product of x and y
i'm going to use little z to denote the
uh strategy profile x y
and we'll also have a operator f
so f z is just you combine the two
gradients with the correct sign okay
and so so f this operator has two nice
properties
so the first one is f is monotone
and this
you can show it not without too much
trouble uh if l is convex and x can
concave y the following inequality is
true for any z and z prime you choose
okay so this is called a monotonicity
and also because the loss function is
smooth
f is actually lipschitz okay and i will
use capital l to denote the lipschitz
constant
all right
okay so
we're interested in finding an
equilibrium
in this set z
the star
so that is equivalent to saying
for any z in this constraint set
this inequality is true so let me
explain why this is true
so the way to think about this is this
tells you
how much more
you can get if you deviate from z-star
essentially
okay
so you want to say z-star is equilibrium
so that's the same as saying that if you
deviate from z star how much more you
can get okay so this term here
essentially captures that okay
and so if you say this is less equal
than zero that means deviating is not
going to help you all right
but that's equivalent to saying this
star is an equilibrium
okay
so um
so i actually want to go to a
a more general setting than just convex
concave max optimization so i want to
talk about
variation in quality monotone variation
inequality
so that is basically the same as what i
wrote here
so i also have a domain z
which is convex and close
so the only thing i'm removing is that i
don't require z to have this structure
which is a product okay
uh i also have an operator f
but now i'm removing this requirement
that f needs to have this form
okay
and the goal now is i want to find a z
star that satisfies exactly this
inequality okay the inequality that
guarantees that z-star is an equilibrium
in the comic's concave game okay
so i think this should be quite easy to
see it is a generalization of the convex
concave game
and uh
so i'm gonna just be mainly talking
about this problem and there is some
benefit for going to this more general
setting
one is that this allows you to go beyond
two player games you can capture
multiplayer games using this model you
can capture what's called the
multiplayer monotone games
and that includes you know interesting
games that have been studied quite a bit
in the literature for example
zero some poly matrix games zero some
socially concave games and so on
okay
so uh
that's the setting i want to uh really
look at
but whenever i say variation and quality
use this notation
feel free to think about it just in the
convex concave as i described here
the results will essentially be the same
all right
okay so uh so the main algorithm i want
to focus on is the extra gradient method
so now i'm really showing you the
algorithm uh in the constraint setting
and uh
so let me just you know explain the
algorithm this is one area of the
algorithm uh using this picture here
okay
so i have a domain z
all right
and uh so zt is the t's iterate of that
algorithm
so first
i will take
uh one gradient step okay
so that step may take me out of
the feasible region okay so eta here is
the step size
and i do a projection so i do l2
projection back to the domain okay
so now i get the
uh
the the half step which is the zt plus
one half so i also call it the midpoint
and now so what i want to do is i want
to figure out what is the gradient at
this midpoint
okay i'm going to update zt using that
gradient okay so i'm doing two gradient
computation that's why it's called the
extra gradient method
uh so okay so i'm using the midpoints
gradient to update zt
again it might take me out of the
feasible region okay
i'll project it again
i get vt plus one
so all this business is one iteration
right
that's the extra graded method and
that's the central algorithm we want to
analyze today
okay
all right so what is the main result we
proved uh in this paper
so
uh
so the theorem we prove says that okay
you take z
to be any complex convex set with
diameter d
take f to be any monotone and outlicious
operator okay
so now
you can take
any step size that's c over l for c
that's a constant between zero and one
okay
so you run eg with that step size
okay
and we'll get the following guarantee so
let me first tell you what is the
convergence measure we're using so we're
using the gap function as the
convergence measure
so the get function is defined as
follows right so you find the maximum z
prime
for this inner product okay
just you know recall that the monotone
vi tries to find a z-star such that this
quantity
is zero it's less equal to zero always
okay so if you actually find equilibrium
or find you know uh the solution of the
vi
even you're maximizing over z prime this
is less equal than zero okay so if i
have approximate solution that might not
be less equal than zero but as long as i
have upper bound then show is very close
to zero you know that means i'm close
okay so that's the convergence measure
i'm going to use and this is the
standard convergence measure so it's not
something we come up with it's a
standard one
and what we show is that this gap
function
uh
decreases in the this particular rate so
the first term here is a constant that
depends on the c you choosing the step
size
uh here uh it's dependent on the time t
the diameter and the lipschitz constant
okay
and uh so i want to say that
so this is for
momentum variation and quality if you go
back to commerce concave games
there is a notion called the primal do
gap which is also used as a convergence
measure
the gap function is an upper bound of
that so it's actually harder to bound
the gap function rather than that all
right
okay
so i'm seeing a result for compact set
uh for the experts in the audience might
be wondering you know is compactness
really needed because uh there are
results for unconstrained settings right
so there is a euclidean space it's not
compact
so it's actually not needed uh you can
remove the boundedness assumption you
just need to adapt the gap function
definition slightly
in the standard way okay so it carries
over to there
okay so i was saying that you know this
uh bound this rate
is tied in a very strong sense so what i
mean by that is actually matches the
lower bound in all three parameters we
have here
the time t the diameter and the
lipschitz constant
so it matches all parameters
okay so the only thing that might not be
high is the constant
all right so the lower bar is due to uh
uh golovkin co-authors
okay so that's the main result
uh questions about this name and the
results
because i'm going to move on to uh
the the proof
yeah
the unconstrained facebook is the form
of the upper bond so you know i have
like d right
there oh unconstrained yes so could you
repeat the question right so the
question is
uh in the unconstrained case we don't
have a d how do we define that function
so there what you say is you change the
definition here you say you look at z
prime
that's within some distance d
of either the
either z star or your current point so
now you have the d you can talk about
there the basically you're not allowed
to move you know arbitrarily far away
from the solution
yeah so that's the definition
and now i mentioned that uh i should
point out like this actually was true
for the unconstrained case the lower
bound
uh
so in some sense this also says that in
the constraint case it's not slower
[Music]
so the question was whether the lower
bound applies to you know all first
order methods or just extra gradient
so i think the answer is that they apply
it to this uh
family of algorithms called
scli was the shortened time there's a
certain notation for stationary
um
what's the the acronym
yeah what's the name
so yeah so it includes like for example
obvia
yeah so they proved this actually for a
fairly general concept though
if you know that average iterate gives
you faster convergence rate
why do we still care about elastic
convergence even if you know it's
yeah so that's a good question so the
question is since we uh already know the
average inter conversion trades whatever
t in these settings why do we care about
last nature convergence rate
well
i think i'll go back to you know the
answer that i gave in the beginning
which is
one it's important to develop tools so
understand what's last year data
convergence because there might be cases
where average iterations
you know
might not be the reasonable thing to do
uh so uh the second one would be that
maybe you're thinking about this you
know as
distributed algorithms
you know every agent is updating their
own strategy using some simple algorithm
and if you only have average rate
convergence you converge to something
called a cce okay
but that's a weaker concept if you have
less interest convergence you can maybe
say really the behavior converges to
natural glue so from a game theoretical
perspective that there is a big
difference between
exactly the third question so is it
impossible to learn any algorithms
for less integration beyond these
familiar algorithms
yeah so uh
the question is whether it's possible to
get a lasting convergence of one over t
i think there is a paper
that does some acceleration
that gives you one over t in the
unconstrained case
um so this is a very recent paper last
year uh
we haven't analyzed that paper yet uh
but i think the approach here might be
might be useful to
but
do
that
algorithm may not have a very natural
interpretation in terms of game dynamics
but uh it does have a one over t uh
leicester convergence rate
okay uh so there's one also question on
the chat here uh
i'm so uh presumably talking about the
practice of this so i understand the
definition of constrained versus
unconstrained can you give some
intuition
which case are we usually in what does
it depend on oh
so
so if you think about training of gas
perhaps the constraints are not
specified explicitly usually it's sort
of specified implicitly using the
regularizers okay
um so if you think about games right if
people are playing games
then uh the constraints are usually very
explicit right so if you think about
people are playing in a two players or
some game and everyone's choosing an
action out of you know a final number of
actions
the constraint is that
you can choose a distribution over these
actions so you're choosing from simplex
so the constraints could be very
explicit
all right
all right
so let me move on uh
okay so uh
so for the rest of the talk i actually
want to show you the approach we use to
prove this result uh
all right
so first uh let me introduce a different
convergence measure
that's actually more useful for us
that was using the get function as the
convergence measure
so here uh i'm defining this new notion
called the projected hamiltonian
and
for many of you in the audience you're
probably familiar with what's called the
hamiltonian so the hamiltonian is
the autonomous square
of the operator okay
so we're adapting that function
uh
so we're adapting a function with this
uh second correction term okay so why do
we do that
so indeed uh if there's no constraint
our definition will give you exactly the
hamiltonian okay so the second term will
be zero
uh so we're introducing the second
correction term
just to deal with the constraints
okay
so uh why do we need this correction
term okay so
so i like to think about uh the
hamiltonian as the kinetic energy okay
so let me explain what i mean by that
so think about minus f as the velocity
at this point okay
so if you look at the autonomous square
of this f
so you can think about that as something
that's proportional to the kinetic
energy okay
so in the unconstrained case of course
that's the right measure for kinetic
energy and if your kinetic energy is
zero that means you're not moving right
so you converge
okay but in the constrained case
even though maybe your minus f
is large it's possible that the velocity
is ticking directly into the constraint
right you're hitting the wall
so the wall is going to stop you
so you're not moving even though minus f
could be big
okay
so even the minus f is big your velocity
could be zero okay
so we're adapting the definition to
reflect that okay so that's really what
we're doing here
and so let's just look at two simple
examples to give you a bit more
intuition
so in the first case
so minus f is taking away from the
constraints
okay so in this case nothing is stopping
you
and really your uh kinetic energy should
be just you know the hamiltonian okay
and that's what our definition will give
you
in the second case
minus f tells you to go this way okay
but you cannot really go this way
because you have constraints here okay
and the the constraint will actually
absorb all the velocity that's
perpendicular to it okay so you can
really just go along the wall right
instead of
go through it
and really so here your velocity will be
this orange i don't know if you can see
the color but the orange vector rather
than the red vector
okay
and our projected hamiltonian will be
the autonomous square of the orange
vector
so that's what our definition would give
i won't explain why exactly this gives
you these two pictures uh but i think
this is the intuition
uh you should have in mind for the rest
of the talk and that should be good
enough
all right so that's the notion we use
yes so
correct so the question is when i'm
looking at a global minimizer here yeah
the answer is yes
all right so that's a projector
hamiltonian
uh it's not hard to argue that this is
uh if you can bounce this quantity it's
good enough to bound the gap okay so
it's some very simple
um
essentially cautious what's okay so if
you can bound the projected hamiltonian
uh you also part on the gap function
okay so we'll instead look at the
projected multiple
all right
okay so what do we know about you know
the projected hamiltonian so it turns
out
without too much trouble you can prove
what's known as the best bitrate
guarantee for the projected hamiltonian
so what what does that mean right so if
you take a constant step size say c over
l for some c
and you run the algorithm for capital t
steps okay
so what you can argue is that there
exists one step t star
such that
the projected hamiltonian is small okay
in particular
uh
one over t small
okay
so that is something you can prove
without too much trouble in fact if
you're in the unconstrained setting this
really follows from even the koplavic
original paper okay
uh so we prove it for the constraint
setting with some extra work but this is
not too difficult
okay so if you run for capital t steps
one of the projected hamiltonians is
going to be small okay
so effectively you want to show that
this function is
so so you are saying there is a d
okay
so
effectively this means that the
hamburger is convex function
so
i'm looking at a maximization over a at
the normal pump at this point z not like
the whole space
so
i don't
so so are there any so you said the
global minimizer let's say the nas makes
correct yes
are there any local minima
and this is nothing no i don't think so
because of this right okay yeah
all right
sorry this follows from the average case
convergence of
it says right so okay search for your
question
the question is whether the best
director falls from the average rate uh
i wouldn't say exactly but the same
proof like from that one proof you can
get both
okay
all right
okay so this passenger convergence is
something more or less follows from the
classical work okay
so uh if you want to get lazy trade
here's one simple strategy okay if you
argue the projected hamiltonian is not
increasing over time
then what is the passage the acetone is
velocity right because it's monotone
okay okay so
so then you know uh we get elastic
convergence
and uh that is the strategy we would
take of course we're not the only one to
realize you know this is a good strategy
to take here uh in fact that's the
strategy used in the unconstrained
setting to prove the lasting convergence
as well
so the the paper by uh call of chain
co-authors uh
they use this they showed that the
they did not exactly show the
hamiltonian is monotone they show the
component cannot increase too much
between you know uh two iterates
under some uh extra conditions
uh there's a recent paper but but that
was enough to prove the last few
conversions there was a recent paper
that the
proves monotonously without this extra
assumption okay in an unconstrained
setting
all right
so
what i want to show you next
is a really simple proof for the
monotonicity of the projector
hamiltonian
and uh
it's really simple in fact all the
details will fit into one slide so uh so
i want to show you that
all right
and uh
so it's uh
uh
it's roughly the same as what they prove
but actually our proof gives you allows
you to take a bigger step size and
arguably simpler okay so let me show you
the proof all right
so
take any step size that's between zero
and one over l okay
and i want to prove to you the
so now it's not the projected harmony
because it's an unconstrained okay so
there's no projection just the
hamiltonian i want to prove to you the
hamiltonian's monotone okay
all right
so
so first i'm giving you two inequalities
so the these are like quite easy to
verify so the first one
this is just a monotonicity
between z k and z k plus one okay so
that's a monotonously
the second one
is deliciousness right the all elliption
is between the endpoint and the midpoint
okay so two
quite uh
self-evident uh constraint uh
inequalities
okay so here's the actual gradient
method
i'm going to use the update rule to do
some change of variables
okay so first i can replace
this difference by
eta times the vector view at the
midpoint right just because the update
rule here
okay so i also do a little change of
variable here
so
zk plus one half minus zk plus one
this i can use the update rule to
replace it in this way
okay
so very simple changing variable using
the update rule
okay so i'm rewriting these two
inequalities after changing the
variables
so this is really just changing uh the
simple change of variable
here i'm doing a little bit extra
that is i'm using the fact that eta
times out is no more than one
okay so subtracting you know one times
this quantity is you know makes it even
smaller
all right so that's the
uh second inequality
okay uh
so let me call the left-hand side here
term a the left-hand side here term b
okay
all right
i'll need one more equation to show you
the proof okay
so i'm looking at the difference to the
hamiltonian okay because there's no
projection it's really the autonomous
square of the two vector fields okay
what i'm doing is all right so i'm going
to add 2a plus b
to this difference
and
the claim is
this is
zero it's an identity
this is exactly zero
nothing else i'm not using anything else
okay
and
very easy to verify you can expand
everything
okay
it's the inner product of this thing
of
in a pro between inner part of that and
this this is zero okay so you can verify
this quite easily
but the the point
is this is zero okay what i get here is
zero
because these two are not negative
really sorry these are these two are
non-positive
so clearly i have ones
all right
that's the proof
uh
i think everything in one side
was relatively big funds okay so
really simple proof uh
but i would say this is something that's
easy to verify
but perhaps not so easy to discover
so if you really think about this
it's not clear why these two
inequalities i mean there are other
monotonicity constraints you can use
there are deliciousness constraints you
can use as well why pick these two
and also why multiply a was two
and just add b
not clear law
okay
so
this is a very simple proof that you
know you can present in your class okay
usually i think the hard question you
will get is like how do you come up with
such a proof
okay so i think this time
i really have an answer for you okay so
the answer is you can use the sum of
squares probably yeah
so
comparing this proof to the result you
cite it in the previous slide but yeah
so
so the previous one i think
one
they use one more constraint to prove
the result
two
their step size eta is uh
i think it's no more than one over
square root two times l so we get a
slightly bigger step size
uh
but okay i don't think these are
fundamental differences
uh i think the main reason i'm showing
this uh
well i mean it's just it's still a
simple proof there's a shorter proof uh
but i think the approach is different so
i think that's the main difference which
i will explain
thanks
okay so i want to show you how uh we
actually discovered this
right
okay so uh
so the way i want to think about
you know this perfect monotonicity
question
is i actually want to think about the
difference of the two uh hamiltonians as
a polynomial okay i want to think about
this as a polynomial
in six n variables okay so let me first
explain notation
so i want to use xl as uh to denote the
else coordinate of a vector x okay
and so y6n variable so i care about six
vectors each n dimensional so the six
vectors are z k z k plus one half z k
plus one and their corresponding vector
fields okay so i care about these six
vectors
uh
and so what i want to do is i want to
prove
that this difference
is not negative
whenever the variables
satisfy the following polynomial
inequalities
okay so the first line of inequality is
the monotonicity
second line will be deliciousness
and the third and the fourth will be the
eg update rule
okay so these are all
polynomial inequalities uh
using these success variables
okay
so that's what i want to prove
all right
so uh
i want to
for a moment forget about actual greater
message okay so i want to think about
more general questions
the more general question is
if you're given a polynomial p of x
and
a semi-algebra set so that's just a set
of points x
that satisfy
polynomial inequalities okay so the f i
and gj's are the inequalities they're
all polynomials
so i want to prove or certify the
non-negativity of the polynomial px
in this semi-algebra set okay
how can i do that
okay so that's a question i want to talk
about the next two sort of exercise and
the answer of that will help us discover
the proof that i'll show you earlier
all right
so uh
an obvious certificate you can think of
is that
maybe p of x
is a sum of squares polynomial what's
the sum of squares polynomial
well as the name suggests if your
polynomial can be
you know decomposed into the sum of
squares of polynomials
you know that's uh you know why it's
called sum of squares polynomial
if you have a sum of squares polynomial
of course it's negative
right it's not only in a negative over w
it's not negative everywhere okay
and we use sigma squared to denote all
sls polynomials
okay
so but this is probably too demanding
right like there's no reason to expect
px will be sum of squares polynomials
and we're not even using the the set w
okay
so here's one possible certificate you
can provide
to say
you know p of x is not negative over w
here's how we can do it
take a bunch of non-negative real
numbers sigma 1 to sigma n
some real numbers phi 1 to phi m okay
and one sos polynomial okay
write p of x
in this way
okay if you can do that
it's a certificate why
s of x is not negative
anywhere okay
second term is zero over w
first term is non-negative over w okay
so that's a certificate okay
all right so
but you can go
to more general forms of certificates
okay
so why only multiply your constraints f
i and gj
with numbers
you can multiply them with polynomials
as well
okay so here what i'm changing is
instead of taking sigma i as a
non-negative real number
take it as a sum of squares polynomial
you can multiply that
and this is another certificate okay
this is a much more general form of
certificate
but you can go to something even more
general
okay
and this is the type of certificate we
use in this paper okay
so i'm doing two extra changes here
one is that i'm no longer trying to just
decompose p of x
i'm multiplying p of x with another
polynomial and try to decompose that
product okay so here q of x is a that's
an sos polynomial
uh i'm also changing this term here okay
so what i'm doing here is i'm inducing
new uh
polynomial inequalities what do i mean
by that so i take
a subset of the fis
and multiply them together
okay
that's a new polynomial
there has been a negative as well right
over w i'm multiplying the negative
polynomials
but that's this product
i multiply that with a
another sum of squared polynomials add
them up
okay so i can do that as well
if i can
write px in this way
okay so that's a certificate for
non-negativity
so all three types of certificates are
sufficient to prove p of x is not
negative
so you might be wondering you know
is there actually necessary in
sufficient conditions
the answer is yes uh you if you go to
something
a bit more general than type three
certificates
it's guaranteed by the positive standard
shots uh i will go into details here but
there is such a form
uh we don't need that in this paper so
uh we actually use
type three and that's good enough for us
[Music]
so i have capital n
inequality constraints of the form f i
greater than zero
and the m is for the equality so here
yeah
all right
okay so that's the type of certificate
you want to use
to certify the negativity
uh
the question is okay how do you find
such a certificate
so one
challenge is
well in the certificate i'm not saying
anything about what's the maximum degree
you want to use for q and sigma and so
on okay
so that's a challenge
uh
but this turns out to be basically the
only barrier okay
so if you restrict the certificate to
have degree no more than two d so what
that means is
you want the left hand side polynomial
to have degree no more than two d
if you can do that you can actually use
what's known as the degree to the sls
programming
to search for such a certificate
so there's an algorithm to do that but
in fact there's a package to do that
all right
so
so let me just tell you a bit more about
what the srs program will have to look
like okay
uh so here there are a few important
parameters so 2d is the largest degree
you can go to and you're looking at
polynomials in n different variables
okay
and the input will be
fixed polynomials so here
p of x is the target volume no you want
to purchase in the negative
the his are the induced non-negative
polynomials with degree number than to
be
gj will be the polynomials or equal to
zero
and uh the decision variables of the sof
programs
will be other polynomials okay so i
think maybe this is something that's
i mean it was confusing for me the first
time i i saw this
uh so you have polynomials as variables
in this program
so qx sigma i and phi j and for qx and
sigma i i want them to be sum of squares
polynomials okay
and i'm writing this as just a
feasibility sls program so the
feasibility is that
i want this and this polynomial to be
some of our
volume
okay this is constraint
so if you remember the type three
certificate i wrote in the previous
slide
if i can find q sigma i and 5
so that this is true
i will discover a type 3 certificate
okay and that will certify the
negativity of p of x
all right
okay so that's the sum of squares
program we use uh in this paper
and
it's quite well known that if you have a
sum of squares program you can convert
it to a semi-definite program
with the following size so k will be the
number decision variables
n is the number of variables in your
polynomial and d is the largest degree
you can use okay so you can convert to
stp at this size
all right
okay so
this is how we discovered the proof so
you solve a sum of square programming
in the unconstrained case you can use
the degree 2 sos program
and that's you know what the what this
proof i showed you earlier
came from
if you want to solve the constraint case
you go to the
we actually went to a degree six sos
program
okay
let me try to wrap up the five minutes
or so
we got a lot of questions so yeah okay
okay
so there's one more component i want to
show you uh that is how you actually use
the sum of squares programming in our
problem
okay so
here is a
naive approach you can take okay
so for any constraint set z
in the n-dimensional cleanup space
you can directly use the sos program
like the sos program i'll show you in
the previous slide to prove the
monotonicity of the projected
hamiltonian okay you can try to do that
but what you would get is a sos program
for polynomials in n variables
and you get
number of constraints of z many decision
variables
okay
so this is something that scales with n
and you know the number of constraints
you need to specify z okay
even if you can solve this what you will
get
is just one proof for this z
right because you're using constraints
for this z
but we want a proof that works for all z
okay so this naive approach will not
give you the proof we want
so instead what we did is that
we first apply what we call the
constraint and dimensional reduction
to show there is a hardest instance
and that hardness instance actually lies
in a constant dimensional space
and it has a very simple geometry the
constraint set only has
in fact three constraints
okay
so now i have a constant size problem
and we can argue in a formal sense that
it's the hardest case
we run the sos on that hardest instance
okay
so small size sos
and now you get a proof for all z
because we prove it for the heart
disease okay
and i just want to point out the fact
that we can do this reduction
is really because the update rule of the
eg algorithm is very low dimensional
okay in particular by that i mean you
only have constant of iterates involved
in the update and you only have two
projections or like constant number
projections
all right
so let me just quickly tell you what's
the constraint reduction we did i won't
have time to talk about dimensional
reduction
but these two actually quite closely
related once you do the constraint
reduction with two extra steps you can
get a dimensional reduction as well okay
all right so what's the constraint
reduction
so like in this naive approach the way
we think about the problem is fix the z
try to figure out what's the
most difficult trajectory that will
violate they try to violate the model
ethnicity
okay
uh
here we're flipping you know the the
order we think about things we say
first fix the trajectory okay fix the
trajectory forget about z fix the
trajectory okay
now think about what constraint sets
could be consistent with this trajectory
okay there could be more than one okay
maybe many constraints that will be
consistent with the trajectory
let's try to pin down what's the hardest
constraint set z that's consistent with
the trajectory
apply sos on that hardest instance
okay so that's what we do
and in fact it's not hard to discover
what's the hardest z uh
and
i'll show you just in this picture
all
right
so this is the trajectory okay i have z
k z k plus one half and z k plus one
all right
if i take one gradient step
it's something different from the
midpoint so i know there's a projection
happening right so there's a projection
if i know this is a projection what do i
know
well i can draw a hyperplane that's
perpendicular to this vector and go
through z k plus one half
right
what i know is the set z
should lie on this half space right so
that i can i can learn
by looking here
okay so you know i take uh
the
the greatest step here
there's a projection happening so i'll
learn another uh
half space
okay
so now with this half split two half
spacer i know z must lie in the
intersection of these two half spaces
okay
all right so we care about the projected
hamiltonian and let's say i know that
the projected hamiltonian as z k
is uh this quantity
by that i mean that a k is the one
that solves this maximization
problem in the correction term
at ak i know it's something in the
normal cone at this point
so i learned another
half space
okay
so really by looking at a projection i
can conclude that
the set z must lie in the intersection
of these three
half spaces
okay so maybe the real z is there i
wouldn't be able to figure out but at
least i know it lies in the intersection
okay
so now
uh i want to tell you know what is the
the hardest z
okay and what do i mean by a z is the
hardest
well a z is hard
if you gives you
a high
projected hamiltonian at the end point
right because that's the part that will
make the monolithic hardest to satisfy
okay
so
so what i need to do is figure out a z
that gives makes this quantity the the
highest while still being consistent
with the trajectory
it's not hard to see
that set
will really just be the intersection of
the three half spaces
okay so you can prove it formally
it's really one line proof i won't do
that here but i think intuitively it's
clear right so the hardest set will be
just the intersection of these three
half spaces
okay
so that's
good because the constraints are simple
only three constraints
i don't need to know what's really the
constraints in z
just these three constraints enough okay
all right so we run the sos
on this instance okay
and
this is my last slide
uh
so i want to show you the proof
really uh
so this is the point v that i want to
prove isn't a negative
okay
so because i only have three constraints
these are the normals of those two you
know three hyperplanes i can re-uh
choose a new bases so that i can write
them in this particular form
right so i only have three vectors i'm
writing them in this one
okay so i want to prove this isn't a
negative
here are the inequalities inequalities
we come up with
so there are eight of them
what i do is
i multiply the target polynomial with
eta square multiply each of them with
these coefficients
i add them up okay so multiply the
left-hand side of these inequalities
with these coefficients i add them up
okay
and here's what we got in the end
okay
it's not really a sum of squares uh but
it's something that's definitely not
negative i get a
square of a polynomial here okay not
negative
here this is clean or negative
here
also a square of something divided by
the autonomous square
also something clearly not negative okay
so this is a cross product here uh i'm
writing
okay so oh this is not negative and i'm
only adding non-negative terms to the
target polynomial so hence the target
polynomial is also negative
all right
that's the proof
uh
yeah so uh
i think this is something that could be
very hard to discover uh using a
traditional approach which is
essentially trial and error
but the sos actually gives you this
all right
okay let me wrap up uh
so uh you know we'll prove the thai last
due to conversions for eg uh
i think uh one interesting thing here is
that uh we provide this new approach
which i think has a lot of potential so
we analyze eg using this method
the one that
something we didn't use here but you
know could be useful
is that the srs program actually has a
lot of flexibility we're only specifying
this as a feasibility problem
you can write it as an optimization
problem as well so you can encode an
objective function there
so you can use it potentially to search
for you know potential functions okay
which we're using here is just you know
we know the projected hamiltonian is a
good measure but
maybe you want to search for potential
function
maybe you can use it to search for the
optimal step size which we did a little
bit in the unconstrained case
and also really the requirement here is
that your algorithm need to have some
kind of low dimensional update rule so
they can do this reduction
uh but you know not only eg has that uh
feature
uh we actually apply this to the
proximal point method uh in the
constraint setting we can also get a
wonderful routine less different
convergence so perhaps there are other
applications
uh thank you for the beautiful talk um
since we are a bit late let's postpone
questions for the coffee break
and uh see you again in 15 minutes at 10
15. thank you